let me pull up this uh this next story
now that we're kind of getting into the
the thick of things here we got the
story from newsweek
targeted assassinations coming if civil
war breaks out adam kinzinger adam
kinzinger has uh spoken on this issue he
spoke with i think cnn uh and the view
and he said that there's a real
possibility of civil war in this country
and it's coming from a guy who is
i wouldn't even call him a republican at
this point but it's kind of weird
because what left and right don't mean
anything anymore whether you're a
democrat or republican is also mostly
meaningless because you could be an
establishment uniparty republican you
could be a progressive democrat or a
corporate democrat
this is just a guy who hates trump
he made a very very good point though he
said people are separating into tribes
people don't live in the same realities
anymore and he believes that if there is
a civil war it's going to be targeted
assassinations that's that's going to be
the level of conflict we see i certainly
hope not
but for all the people who you know even
to this day still these establishment
leftists want to mock me saying that i'm
crazy for bringing up this idea of civil
war it's really funny now when i'm you
know trolling on on twitter and i see
them posting like you know i used to
make fun of him because he wouldn't stop
talking about civil war but now the
guardian and newsweek and and even the
new york times are talking about it so
like i don't know man maybe something's
happening it's like yeah maybe i wasn't
wrong to say i feel like we're heading
in this direction when you've got
people that are choosing their politics
based on whether they hate you or not
like the alec baldwin thing or the
freedom convoy the workers of the world
are uniting and the left opposes it yo
this makes literally no sense the people
who literally say that they are for the
blue collar is exactly the ones who are
trying to constantly attack the blue
collar it's it's it's backwards and look
under president trump the one thing i've
talked about and i talked about this
with congressman jim jordan you know the
republicans were looked at as kind of
the wine and cheese party for the
longest time right what president trump
did was he brought it back to where the
republican party is about the beer and
blue jeans party yeah we are the party
of the american worker we are the party
of the blue-collar worker and that's
what i love to be a part of that changed
so fast in my lifetime that the
republicans became the blue card party
cup party blue collar party well you
know you know why democrats are white
collar what the heck the republicans and
the democrats were both corporate shills
the democrats feigned supporting the
working class when donald trump stormed
the gates the establishment uh
republicans fled
the lincoln project their democrats now
i mean they claim their their principled
republicans but once they've
accomplished their mission we're going
to make sure trump doesn't get reelected
they come out and go
uh donate to us anyway because
republicans are bad
or to our sex scandals that went on in
lincoln
let's ignore those let's ignore those
right but i'm you know you know with
what uh kinzinger is saying we also have
another article from the guardian that
where they said we're in the civil war
it's here we've had the new york times
saying it ray dalio a billionaire has
come out and said it again yesterday
that if you look at legislation in this
country republicans
are being accused of voter suppression
democrats are being accused of stripping
voter security neither side agrees the
other side is working you know honestly
and legitimately
i don't think it matters if who's right
you know you sitting at home you think
well i know which side is right you know
we're right i'm right that's not
relevant to the point the point is if
neither side agrees they both think they
are right it doesn't matter it's kind of
like fighting is going to stop democrats
are looking at the ship and the captain
is in the ship's
ship and it's sailing but the captain
was psychopathic it was donald trump and
we can't have a psychopath piloting the
ship the republicans are looking at the
democrats is the ship is shooting
explosives in every direction and
killing everything around it but so it
doesn't they're not less it's less about
the captain to them it's but it's no no
i i i see but i i think that we're at
the political civil war i i don't think
and it's it's spiraling out towards the
american people so what's happening is
is that
you know president trump came in and he
kind of unveiled that there is
corruption and all this on both sides
and he wouldn't be part of the swamp he
wouldn't be part of the establishment
because one he can't be bought and he
didn't need it but the thing that we're
we're seeing right now is where people
have woken up
and and it's it's now where we have
identified even more strongly the
two-party system and we're on opposing
pendulums you know it's now swing
extreme left-swinging extreme right and
the people are reacting to that but you
know here's the issue and to address
what you said ian as well it's not going
extreme right it's going center right
far left center right far left if you
look at pew's research on this from 1994
there's a scale from zero to ten zero
being far left ten being far right in
1994 the democrats were a five they were
centrists and the republicans were a six
center-right
in 2004 the democrats moved over i think
to a four jumping one point to the left
and republicans jumped about a point to
the left to a five
republicans are at 6.5 right now they're
a half point more right wing more
conservative than they were in 1994 but
democrats jumped from five to a two
meaning they're three points further
left the jump is absolutely on the left
no no argument that they're the most
radical zero argument on that i mean and
and the problem is that we have to try
and balance the scale as cons i tell
people all the time like look
it's like this class right so i'm a
conservative the republican party is
nothing more than a repository for the
the conservative ideals that i have
the problem is that we have too many
republicans like adam kinzinger who
claims to be a republican who are not
willing to protect and not willing to
actually help to conserve
those values that are actually in there
that makes us republicans that's that's
the difference or americans or americans
what the january that's what it is it's
americans versus anti-americans now that
that's what it comes down to it really
is and um i think it's funny because
it's the old trope of uh glenn beck or
hannity you know they hate america and
i'm like well they really do and they
all right i don't know i don't want to
fall into that no they do bro bro i
don't think there's a vey man i think we
all want different we all love america
and want it to be different technically
you're right there's no they in that
when we refer to the left it's an it's a
very very large group of different
political factions with shared common
interests but it's it's it's not
completely unified corporate democrats
obviously don't want communism the
communists don't like the corporate
democrats but they unify around certain
issues the same is true for republicans
center right traditional conservatives
religious folk you've got the post
liberals who are now finding themselves
with republicans and that's a pro-choice
pro-life this disagreement but the issue
i really do think comes down to a few
fundamental issues do you like this
country or not do you think this country
is inherently evil or not do you believe
in the constitution
are you authoritarian or libertarian
there is a they when we say that i'm
referring to people who outright don't
like the constitution so
constitutionalists and i don't like to
say
that because of the codependency
left and right are two words that mean
basically tribe one tribe two yeah call
it tribe a and b you know how about this
it's true you know we don't want anyone
to be lesser so we'll say tribe one and
tribe a
nice everybody can be you know whatever
but when i look at adam kinzinger and he
comes out and he says there's going to
be targeted assassinations you know the
the right has lost their mind or
whatever i'm like bro you're the one on
the january 6 committee issuing these
subpoenas and trying to put the former
administration in prison yeah
i'm not talking about the the the
investigation i'm talking about filing
subpoenas against former staff members
and threatening them with prison because
they refuse to comply
with what what the other side views is
unconstitutional well let me just let me
just ask this question though you know
he's acting like this is something new
are we not calling the incident that
involved uh representative steve scalise
a targeted assassination yeah i mean we
had a left-winger who came bernie
sanders guy and literally shot
and nearly killed steve scalise almost
so killed a bunch of people that's
that's right i mean so my point is is
that you know the the he can't say that
it's just now what what
for me this is adam kenzinger just
trying to stay relevant for me this is
adam kenzinger trying to position his
next job next to whoopi goldberg or on
the cnn he may be late to the party but
he's not wrong when when rand paul got
attacked and he lost a piece of his
lungs they celebrate it to this day they
thought it was hilarious not every
single democrat no but but a lot of them
when donald trump was attacked at the
white house and they tore the barricades
down set fire to a guard post and
torched the church and trump was ushered
into the emergency uh bunker they
laughed at him in the corporate press
the problem with they were going to talk
about insurrection attacking the white
house and breaking down the barriers and
assaulting federal agents i think that
was
threatening
the united states yeah and exactly to
this day they laughed that they did it
right so so when they come out and they
cry oh it's an insurrection i'm like yo
i literally don't care what you think
y'all are celebrating you know i'll say
this your booze need
your booze mean nothing i've seen what
makes you cheer never a more apt
statement i know it's a joke from rick
and morty but it's completely applicable
these people cheer when they try to burn
down a church in front of the white
house and try to breach the barricades
and injure federal federal officers set
fire to a guard post and then they boo
when right wingers ride at the capitol
yo i don't care about who's writer who's
wrong the fact is both sides
are engaged in an escalation of hyper
polarization
and i think
there i i don't see any way this this
this comes back together it's sort of i
think that we need to create the
children we need to teach start teaching
the kids now because what what's gonna
happen is they're gonna laugh at other
people's trauma violence and like see
someone else get hurt a political rival
and they'll laugh and then kids will see
that and as they grow up these people
don't realize they're laughing at their
political rivals getting hurt but if
kids see that and then decide they don't
like you and you were the one that was
hurting that laughing at that other
person they're gonna start doing that to
you and laughing at you it's to become a
cycle it's already happened there have
been kids who have been brutally beaten
for not wearing masks we need to help
the kids we really need to seize control
of the narrative and communicate to
these children well this is the thing
it's not just about the radical left
that's a huge part of it and there's
absolutely no doubt that the left is far
more radical than the right is currently
it's but it's also a question of how
insane the center has gotten in what is
just considered normal moderate politics
the fact that for the past two years
children have been forced to wear masks
in school and anyone who's spoken out
against that or said i'm not going to
cover my face has been perceived as if
there's some kind of maniac who wants to
go around spreading viruses and killing
people
even though and i know we can't get into
some of the details on the the cdc here
but
the problem is
the center has gotten so crazy
and when you look at where they're at
now you start to peer into the past and
realize things have been far outside of
anything even remotely reasonable for a
very long time for example well
it's partisan but when you look at the
things that democrats and republicans
are willing to come together and agree
on they're all really terrifying too
it's the reasonable center that tells us
that we have to go to these wars in the
middle east that cost trillions of
dollars it's the reasonable center that
told us that we needed to spend all of
the money and raise the debt ceiling and
now we're 30 trillion dollars in debt i
don't i don't think so i don't think so
you don't think it's the reason
these are the bipartisan things that the
left and right i agree with tim on this
i don't think it's a reasonable center
at all well i'm using i'm using it's
reasonable here no no
nancy pelosi and rachel maddow that you
know sure the people advocating for war
are not reasonable centrists they're
corporatists democratic you know party
whatever no yeah no exactly my point is
like that represents the position of the
status quo that's not some radical
position that's outside of the system
and that's what i'm saying when i'm
referring to the radical center i'm
saying these are the things that the
left and right agree upon and the things
that they have in common are actually in
many cases way more insane than the
things that separate them
i'll tell you what's very interesting to
me though and i i i posted an article
recently about this you know when
president trump came into office
everyone argued that he was going to
launch the next world war three yep you
know and this is a guy who literally
could not have gotten us to a safer
position i mean created the abraham's
accord started creating an arab
coalition to be able to fight their own
wars so we don't have to be
interventionist started looking at
drawdown so that we could get out of you
know afghanistan and iraq and all these
other areas and start focusing on the
america first agenda meanwhile the thing
about is the democrats who are actually
saying this now where are we right now
we're literally deploying troops to be
able to go into ukraine and other areas
to fight against russia creating the
cold war or the 1920s all over again and
these are the exact people who are
pointing fingers at the republican party
yeah
when they were complaining about him
potentially starting a civil war they
were just upset that they weren't going
to get to do it first if he ever did
well good thing for them they actually
were responsible for a lot of it yeah
i feel like exactly the night is always
dark for the dawn man i'm hoping so i've
been listening to dave smith he went in
rogan a couple days ago and was talking
about the war in yemen and about uh the
united states relations with saudi
arabia and like saudis like saud is like
one of the most gruesome regimes in the
world you know it's a
dictatorship kingdom and they treat
people they're women horribly and but
god yada yada goes on and on but they're
just bombing farms in yemen and fishing
boats and murdering people murdering
generations of humans
and the us is selling them weapons to do
it
maybe not to do it they're selling the
weapons
you're failing to understand though also
what the proxy militias from iran the
houthis are doing i mean they literally
shut down and attacked saudi aramco they
actually went in there they're launching
missiles last week they just launched
another missile it landed in the uae
that killed some of the people there so
i mean
the bottom line is that the people that
saudi are actually fighting against are
the iranian proxy militias that were
down in the gulf of aden and all those
other areas while i agree with you we
necessarily shouldn't be involved in
that war and that's a war between the
middle east and that region and for
their own stability and things like this
and i'm again i'm anti-interventionists
you know the idea of being able to
support allies or supporting the others
i mean this is this is one of those
areas where it starts to become a
quagmire how deep do you get in but i'll
tell you right now though it's not like
saudi was just going out there and
saying oh well here's some random
farmers we're going to kill them no no
these were actually houthi rebels who
had actually launched attacks and who
were actually killing saudis and killing
uae soldiers and things like this over
in the area and are still launching
missiles and rockets into abu dhabi
still today so you're saying they're
firing the missiles from iran and then
they're targeting yeah they're actually
firing them from yemen and launching
into other areas are we sure they're not
false flags oh we're 100 also so here's
the thing so the problem and i just want
to mention this you're absolutely
correct that the houthi rebels do a lot
of horrible things they have child
soldiers but the problem is whenever you
look at any conflict in the middle east
you're going to see a lot of evil on
both sides and there's truth in that
with respect to to any conflict you see
even if you're rooting for a particular
side war crimes are common unfortunately
but i will say this there is a blockade
preventing food from entering yemen and
tens of thousands of people are starving
to death civilians have been made the
target of the warfare here but that's
always the case you always have to
collateral damage going back to your
point do you have proof well of course
you do look at the u.n security council
look back when you either had bon ki
moon who was the actual general
secretary or even gutierrez where they
actually caught the iranian ships who
were actually shipping in mid-range
ballistic missiles into the houthis
which is a violation of resolution 2231
or the jcpoa so there is factual like
you know
proof where the iranians were actually
supporting the houthis to be able to
launch attacks against saudi arabia so
that's not anything that's even up for
debate when it's actually been caught by
international thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you